2ヶ月ぶりに静岡に帰ってきたはじめしゃちょーであったが
俺に家は大きく荒れ果てていた
2ヶ月間も人は家を放置すると部屋が荒れてしまい
廃墟と化してしまう
俺の予想が正しければ
この地下は...
とても....
とても汚いはずだ...
ねぇ？汚いよね？
二ヶ月間汚い部屋を放置するとどうなっていたか...
ちょっと僕、帰ってきて初めて今地下に行くんで
見ていこうと思います。
ゴキブリ出た瞬間、俺はもう帰るよ？
ぶっちゃけゴキブリさえいなければ大概な気がするんだよなぁー
いきます
うわ...
ところてん...
やべ...やべ...やべ...
東京行く前に掃除したんですけど、
掃除した物を捨てる時間がなくて
それを全部地下にまとめて置いていたのですごいことになっていますよ。
ちょっと　見よ
イ”ィィィ
すごいザマです...
普通にゴキブリいそうなんだけど...
基本　地下は
動画で使わなくなった物とかいらなくなった物を
ポイ　ポイ　ポイってやっていく所なんで
すっげーダンボールとか、いろんなものがあるんですけどもぉ...
ゴキブリ出た瞬間、もう俺は終わりだから...
ふ”ぇぇぇぃ！！
ちょっと..
.カメラマン....
お願い。
絶対いるでしょこのレベルだと...
うわ　うわ　うわ
後輩）絶対居ますよこれｗ
あ”ぁ”ぁ”ぁぁぁぁ
何だこれ！？
後）え、でか
は）なにこれ
後）誰のゴミ？
あまり物の牛ふんですね
なにこれ
え、俺これ知らないよ？
うわっ
え、なに
うぉぉ...
ハハハｗ
アァァァ！
これどうやってこれ解き放てと
ちょっと一回中身だけ見てみましょう。
俺知らないもん。知らないでしょ？
後）知らないです。
開け切れないっていうこの
だってこれさ、だってもうあれしかないじゃん
とりあえず開けますね一回
ウハッハッ
だってこんな開けずらいことある？
えだってえ、なになになに
後）え、まって箱に箱じゃないですか？これは
えぇ
ボックス　イン　ボックス？
後）ボックス　イン　ボックスや
ボックス　イン　ボックスやなこれは
まって
後）まって
まってなにこれ
え？
なにこれ
なんかベットっぽくね？
鉄の塊だよ
こっちだよ気になるのは
もうどう開けたらいいか分かんないんだよな
どう..あ！あ、でもこっちに切り口がある
ほれ
こっちなら切り口があるから
いきます
あい
おぉおい
ぇ
ねぇ
足じゃね
後）足だ
後）え、足だ！
ワーハッハッハッ
は）まって
後）怖い怖い
足が入ってる
後）事件の香りがする
ほら、ほらほら
後）大丈夫ですかこの動画
ほら
後）あ、ほんま、え、ほんま
４本だ、一本足りない
後）え..
後）さわ、触っても大丈夫ですか
うわっ
後）うわぁあ
ひゃっはっはっはっ
後）マジで怖いから
てことは、こっちいけば顔が見れるってことだな
おもろなってきたで
こうゆう展開を待っとんたんや
うぉい
あ、やばいまじだこれ
後）見たい見たくない
あぁい
後）やばい
後）あぁい
あっはっ
後）ちぎりましょちぎりましょ
いきます
後）はい
まじでこれやばいべ
後）やばいですよ
いきます
後）はい
はあ..はあ...
マジで怖くない？
後）怖い
いきます
えっ
後）えっ
まってまってまってまって
後）事件の香りがする
まって
まって！！
え！まって
え、え、まっ、えっ
ガチもんだー
後）こんにちわー
わあぁあぁあ！
後）うわっ
後）待って、待って
後）怖いよ、でかいよ
うわっ
後）でっ(笑)
後）でかいよ
後）はじめさん位ありますよ
でかいな
うぇ
は）いぃい
後）いぃい
てかどうすんのまじで